130 milliarden gegen die korona krise
die bundesregierung beschließt weniger
mehrwertsteuer
extra geld für familien und mehr prämien
für e-autos um die wirtschaft
anzukurbeln
neue spur im fall der verschwundenen
madeleine nach 13 jahren fahndung ohne
ergebnis steht jetzt ein deutscher unter
mordverdacht
von küste zu küste demonstrationen gegen
polizeigewalt in den usa auch vier
amtsvorgänger von donald trump
unterstützen die proteste und fordert
ein ende der rassendiskriminierung
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber einen sehr guten abend
hinein an einem sehr ereignisreichen
nachrichten tag den wir für sie jetzt
zusammenfassen alles relevante in den
kommenden zwanzig minuten
deutschland bekommt ein gewaltiges
konjunkturpaket um die gewaltige
rezession zu bekämpfen
130 milliarden euro wird das kosten und
soll in ganz vielen bereichen die
wirtschaft ankurbeln
größter einzelposten die mehrwertsteuer
david sauer gibt den überblick von juli
bis jahresende wird die mehrwertsteuer
auf waren und dienstleistungen von 19
auf 16 prozent gesenkt der ermäßigte
satz von sieben auf fünf prozent kosten
rund 20 milliarden euro pro kind gibt es
300 euro einmalzahlung die aber mit dem
kinderfreibetrag verrechnet werden 3
milliarden euro gehen in den ausbau von
kitas die krise belastet die
sozialsysteme die beiträge werden
deshalb auf 40 prozent vom bruttolohn
gedeckelt das kostet 5,3 milliarden euro
allein dieses jahr den kommunen drohen
hohe steuerausfälle vor allem bei der
gewerbesteuer mit etwa sechs milliarden
euro will der bund das ausgleichen
die deutsche bahn bekommt vom bund 5
milliarden euro neues eigenkapital
der öffentliche nahverkehr wird mit 2,5
milliarden gefördert besonders
gebeutelte unternehmen werden zusätzlich
mit maximal 25 milliarden euro
unterstützt das soll eine pleitewelle
verhindern
größter bereich im konjunkturpaket
klimaschutz und zukunftstechnologien
dafür sollen insgesamt 50 milliarden
euro aufgewendet werden
die regierungsparteien haben lange
darüber gebrütet und loben das ergebnis
jetzt als kraftpaket mit wumms ökonomen
sagen mehr geht kaum aber es gibt auch
kritik nicht zuletzt an den enormen
kosten christiane hübscher mit mehr dazu
zeit für einen was nun frau merkel die
kanzlerin verteidigte am abend im zdf
das überraschend große nach corona
hilfsprogramm
da mussten wir mutig reagieren um dem
etwas entgegen zu setzen denn wir wollen
ja schnell möglichst zu unserem
wohlstand zurück und das heißt menschen
müssen
kaufen können mit 130 milliarden gegen
die rezession mutig sagen die einen
prinzip gießkanne die anderen der
finanzminister nennt es letzte nacht mit
wumms aus der krise kommen wir können
das gut hinbekommen weil wir in den
letzten jahren sehr ordentlich
gewirtschaftet haben weil wir über
rücklagen verfügen weil wir mit dem
nachtragshaushalt den wir anfang des
jahres beschlossen haben als es losging
mit der korona krise uns auch ein
polster angelegt haben der bundestag
muss nun schnell gesetze aus dem
konjunkturpaket machen grundsätzlich
gelungen heißt es heute mehrheitlich aus
der opposition
das konjunkturpaket der bundesregierung
ist besser als befürchtet gerade auch
aufgrund des großen drucks aus der
gesellschaft von der klimabewegung hat
die bundesregierung noch die kurve
gekriegt die abwrackprämie zum glück
rausgestrichen in wir die verbraucher
unterstützen wollen dann müssen wir die
steuern senken die bei den verbrauchern
auch ankommen das ist die mehrwertsteuer
insofern ist das ein richtiger schritt
was mir bei dem paket der großen
koalition sorgen macht ist dass es 57
neue ausgabe punkte gibt aber null
einsparvorschläge und die große
koalition an dieser stelle auch die
antwort schuldig bleibt wer das
eigentlich alles bezahlen soll das sind
natürlich am ende des tages die
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler
die wirtschaft sieht gute impulse um
wieder zum laufen zu kommen meint aber
das geld müsse nun vor allem schnell
fließen
denn wenn die betriebe pleite gehen
bevor die konjunkturimpulse ankommen
dann ist keinem gedient und nur wenn
jobs und unternehmen bestehen bleiben
dann sitzt das geld auch beim
konsumenten wieder locker die kommunen
bleiben zwar auf ihren schulden sitzen
werden dafür aber künftig bei den herz
vier kosten vom bund unterstützt das
gilt vor allen dingen für die kosten bei
unterkunft und heizung das wird etwa
vier milliarden jährlich ausmachen das
begrüßen wir außerordentlich
es ist besser als die
altschuldenregelung der staat muss dem
ganzen land wieder auf die beine helfen
ein konjunkturprogramm das viele neue
schulden hinterlässt zu zahlen auch von
der nächsten generation kurz noch eine
politische analyse unterlagen abend das
ist viel teurer geworden jetzt als es im
vorfeld geheißen hatte wie viel
vorbereitung auf den wahlkampf ist denn
da jetzt bereits drin
wieviel schielen auf das kommende
wahljahr also vermutlich ist der
wahlkampf nicht das primäre ziel dafür
ist die krise zu großen dafür sind auch
die erwartungen zu groß die sich da
jetzt an die bundesregierung richten in
dieser krise aber natürlich ist es kein
zufall dass in dem paket sehr deutlich
die drei handschriften der beteiligten
parteien zu erkennen sind
es ist jetzt so etwas wie die letzte
große chance der großen koalition zu
zeigen was sie kann und was sie in der
krise auch bewegen kann und damit wird
das konjunkturpaket zu einer
visitenkarte für den bundestagswahlkampf
20 21 da kann das kann ein zahlen auf
die parteien das kann ihnen stimmen
bringen wenn es gelingt das birgt aber
eben auch das risiko wenn das paket
nicht funktioniert das dann die parteien
bei der nächsten wahl auch die quittung
dafür kassieren das ist also ein spiel
mit gemischten karten statt einer
herzlichen dank in so einem gewaltigen
paket liegt auch eine chance
die frage ist wie nutzt man die wie
nachhaltig ist das ganze wie sehr er
weist es diesem land den weg in die
zukunft gerade was den schutz des klimas
angeht und im hinblick auf einen schub
für die digitalisierung volker dutschek
hat die verschiedenen punkte dazu mal
abgeklopft
hier wo der wind übers meer pfeift gibt
es einen riesen energiepotenzial da
könnte man per windkraft eine menge
wasserstoff produzieren
deutschland soll nämlich beim
wasserstoff als energieträger die nummer
eins in der welt werden so der
ehrgeizige plan der regierungskoalition
9 milliarden euro allein für
investitionen in diese technologie die
bundesregierung nimmt viel geld in die
hand auch bei den anderen investitionen
in der klimatechnologie wer künftig ein
elektroauto kauft kann beim bund eine
prämie von 6000 euro beantragen
25 milliarden euro gehen in den ausbau
der ladesäulen in fr
struktur wer wenig co2 ausstoß muss dann
auch wenig kfz steuer zahlen
nicht alle maßnahmen finden bei experten
zustimmung das paket verdient durchaus
das prädikat zukunftspaket aber in
punkto klimaschutz und nachhaltigkeit
muss nachgelegt werden
denn sonst werden wir die klimaziele
nicht erreichen also da würde ich jetzt
wenn ich eine schulnote geben würde eine
drei plus geben aber mit aussicht auf
verbesserung digitalisierung bedeutet
vorsprung deswegen will der staat auch
in diesem bereich stärker investieren
vorgesehen ist eine komplette
digitalisierung der verwaltung der etat
für künstliche intelligenz wird
vergrößert 5 milliarden euro bis 2025
und beim netzausbau soll es deutlich
voran gehen 5g qualität bis 2025
flächendeckend im ganzen land gut findet
dass die digitale wirtschaft also die
kanzlerin hat uns ja wirklich feine
mutiges konzept versprochen wir sind in
der tat nicht enttäuscht worden und man
sich dass fast ein drittel aller
investitionen im konjunkturpaket zum
thema digitales gewählt worden sind das
heißt wir gehen die themen an die
wichtig sind
eins ist jetzt schon sicher nach den
kurzfristigen hilfen in der kroner krise
reichen die geplanten konjunkturhilfen
weit über die derzeitige
legislaturperiode hinaus und dann gucken
wir noch mal ein bisschen genauer auf
die mehrwertsteuer mehrwertsteuer runter
zumindest für ein halbes jahr das ist ja
jetzt erst mal relativ einfach zu
verstehen aber die frage was folgt
daraus für uns alle dazu valeria in
frankfurt an der börse valerie heißt das
automatisch alles wird billiger
das müssen wir erstmal sehen aber
angesichts der ausfälle wäre es sicher
verlockend die senkung nicht an die
kunden weiterzugeben aber die erfahrung
aus anderen ländern zeigt dass die
preise zum teil eben doch fallen schon
allein weil der wettbewerb viele dazu
drängt kurzfristig wird die
mehrwertsteuer senkung den umsatz also
vermutlich anschieben die gefahr ist
aber groß dass der konsum danach wieder
ein bericht in der regierung scheint man
darauf zu setzen dass sich die
wirtschaft dann soweit erholt hat dass
sie den einbruch ganz gut verkraftet
weil aber du bleibst noch moment bei uns
denn es gab heute noch eine weitere
schwer zu fassende milliardensumme dabei
geht es um die europäische zentralbank
sie weitet wegen corona
not kaufprogramm für anleihen noch mal
deutlich aus 600 milliarden zusätzlich
wollen die zentralbanker ausgeben
insgesamt jetzt 1,35 billionen euro wenn
die ezb als großer käufer am markt
antritt dann wird es für staaten und
unternehmen leichter sich günstig geld
zu leihen weil er die welche folgen
haben da diese extra milliarden im
ankaufprogramm der ezb jetzt für uns
alle
also vor allem sparer sind die
leidtragenden weil die zinsen eben
dauerhaft niedrig bleiben und wer viel
geld bei der bank bunker der muss sogar
drauflegen in form von negativzinsen die
ezb übrigens begründet die aufstockung
damit dass sie mit einem gigantischen
konjunktureinbruch rechnet und hofft
dass die eurozone damit wieder auf die
beine kommt vor allem schuldengeplagte
länder wie italien völlig unklar aber
ist wann die ezb überhaupt wieder
aussteigt aus diesen anleihekäufen
europa gewöhnt sich nämlich langsam
daran dass die ezb als retterin in der
not einspringen stadt selbst nach einer
lösung zu suchen
valerie haller frankfurt herzlichen dank
um das konjunkturprogramm geht es auch
gleich nach uns bei was nun frau merkel
bettina schausten und peter frey haben
fragen an die bundeskanzlerin
kinderbonus mehrwertsteuer stromkosten
was genau im milliarden paket alles drin
steckt all das gibt's kompakt
zusammengefasst zum nachlesen in der
zdf- heute- app es gibt viele weitere
wichtige nachrichten heute im fall des
ermordeten kasseler
regierungspräsidenten walter lübke gab
es razzien in zwölf bundesländern im
visier der ermittler sind 40
beschuldigte sie sollen sich in sozialen
netzwerken mit hass kommentaren zum fall
strafbar gemacht haben
der cdu politiker war vor einem jahr auf
der terrasse seines wohnhauses in
nordhessen mit einem kopfschuss getötet
worden
die bundesanwaltschaft geht davon aus
dass der schütze aus
rechtsextremistischen motiven gehandelt
hat und jetzt ein kriminalfall der die
polizeibehörden seit 13 jahren in atem
hält und die öffentlichkeit auch der
fall madeleine eine neue spur führt die
ermittler jetzt zu einem deutschen er
steht unter verdacht madeleine mccann
ermordet zu haben gucken wir kurz zurück
mai 2007 das damals drei jahre alte
britische mädchen verschwindet spurlos
während eines familienurlaubs in
portugal aus einer ferienanlage
jahrelang wird international nach
madeleine gesucht die eltern wenden sich
immer wieder an die öffentlichkeit
auch sie geraten zwischenzeitlich unter
verdacht tausende hinweise gingen bei
der polizei ein
und jetzt die spur nach deutschland
holen seit dem verschwinden der damals
dreijährige maddie mccann wollen die
eltern nur eins die wahrheit über das
schicksal ihrer tochter herausfinden
möglicherweise sind sie ihr nun ein
stück näher gekommen im visier der
ermittler ist ein deutscher der in kiel
bereits eine haftstrafe verbüßt ermittle
die staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig
gegen einen 43 jährigen deutschen
staatsangehörigen wegen des verdachts
des mordes
daraus können sie entnehmen dass wir
davon ausgehen dass das mädchen tot ist
bei den beschuldigten handelt es sich um
einen mehrfach vorbestraften
sexualstraftäter so wurde er wegen
kindesmissbrauchs und besitzes von
kinderpornografie bereits verurteilt der
verdächtige soll sich zur tatzeit rund
um die praia da luz in portugal
aufgehalten haben dort einbrüche in
ferienanlagen verübt haben
die ermittler veröffentlichten in der
gestrigen zdf sendung aktenzeichen xy
ungelöst bilder von fahrzeugen mit denen
der verdächtige damals unterwegs war ein
auffälliger vw camper wenn das zweite
fahrzeug ein jaguar wurde am tag nach
maddies verschwinden auf einen neuen
halter umgemeldet
der beschuldigte soll zwischen 1995 und
2007 in diesen zwei häusern an der
algarve gewohnt haben zeugen die sich
erinnern soll nun helfen wer weiß wer
diese wohnungen und zimmer bis 2007 im
mai 2007 genutzt hat die feststellung
und wahrnehmung dazu werden auch für
unsere ermittler von immenser bedeutung
jede menge indizien ein tatverdacht aber
es fehlt immer noch der entscheidende
beweis
die eltern haben die suche nach ihrer
tochter nie aufgegeben sich immer wieder
an die öffentlichkeit gewandt
auch nach den neuesten ermittlungen
ließen sie ausrichten dass sie immer
noch die hoffnung haben madlin lebendig
wieder zu sehen
unser nächstes thema er selbst nannte es
nur als offene geschichte
in österreich wurde daraus eine
regierungskrise heinz christian strache
und der skandal um das ibiza video sind
seit heute gegenstand eines
untersuchungsausschusses im parlament in
wien vor gut einem jahr fegten die
korruptionsvorwürfe den österreichischen
rechtspopulisten aus dem amt des vize
kanzlers und dem vorsitz seiner ft
der u ausschuss soll jetzt prüfen ob die
regierung von vp und sp höhe zwischen
2017 und 19
käuflich war und dann schauen wir in die
usa in ein aufgewühltes land die
staatsanwaltschaft geht nun härter gegen
die vier ex polizisten vor die an dem
einsatz gegen george floyd in
minneapolis beteiligt waren
der ehemalige polizist der seinen knie
auf flirts hals gedrückt hatte wird nun
nicht mehr wegen totschlags sondern
wegen mordes angeklagt seine drei ex
kollegen müssen sich wegen
mittäterschaft verantworten
der brutale polizeieinsatz gegen den
afroamerikaner treibt immer mehr
menschen auf die straßen überall im land
elmar theveßen
sie werden mehr immer mehr wie hier in
washington letzten acht
auch die bilder aus los angeles zeigen
da kommt etwas in bewegung und ein
früherer us präsident auch das gab es
sony vermutlich die proteste dieses land
wurde auf protest gegründet man nannte
ist die amerikanische revolution jeder
ausdruck unserer tiefsten ideale wurde
gewonnen durch anstrengungen die
unbequem sind für den status quo
unbequem für donald trump dass ihm sein
ehemaliger verteidigungsminister mertes
nun verfassungsbruch vorwirft er habe
die demonstranten am weißen haus
vertreiben lassen
er spaltet das land mit voller absicht
und missbrauche das militär für seine
zwecke niemals hätte ich gedacht dass
soldaten befohlen wird die
verfassungsmäßigen rechte ihrer
mitbürger zu verletzen
schon gar nicht für einen bizarren
fototermin für den gewählten obersten
befehlshaber trump beschimpfte mathis
darauf per twitter als meist
überschätzten general der welt das alles
bestärkt offenbar menschen in allen
bevölkerungsschichten in ihrem wunsch
für ein besseres amerika eines in dem
wie soll schärfer sagt kinder nicht um
ihr leben fürchten müssen weil sie
schwach sind dunkler als andere menschen
heute wird hier in minneapolis die große
gedenkfeier stattfinden für deutschland
russlands behörden kämpfen mit massiven
umweltschäden am nordpolarmeer aus einem
sibirischen kraftwerk sind bereits vor
knapp einer woche
20.000 tonnen diesel ausgelaufen und
verseuchen nun die flüsse präsident
wladimir putin sagte er habe erst mit
zwei tagen verzögerung von diesem unfall
erfahren
er rief den nationalen notstand aus
satellitenbilder machen die umwelt
katastrophe deutlich nach angaben des
kraftwerkbetreibers war an einem tank
ein leck entstanden zurück nach
deutschland und wir gucken auf die
aktuellen corona zahlen hier bei uns
danach gehen die neuinfektionen weiter
zurück im durchschnitt der vergangenen
sieben tage steckten sich täglich 370
menschen mit dem corona virus an
seit beginn der pandemie registrierte
die johns hopkins universität mehr als
184 1000 infizierte davon gelten über
167.000 als genesen 8600 27 menschen
sind in verbindung mit dem virus
gestorben
in corona zeiten soll der kampf gegen
andere krankheiten wie masern polio oder
typhus nicht vernachlässigt werden sagt
eine große online geberkonferenz und
stellt milliarden für impfstoffe bereit
für kinder in den ärmsten ländern der
welt
allein in deutschland gibt 600 millionen
beteiligt einer initiative ist auch der
us milliardär bill gates der wegen
seines engagements massiv angefeindet
wird von impfgegnern und anhängern von
verschwörungs erzählungen ja sind herein
berichtet
es ist gerade auch eine organisation wie
garvey der globalen allianz für
impfstoffe und immunisierung zu
verdanken dass es bei der bekämpfung von
krankheiten die polio typhus und masern
zuletzt viele erfolge gegeben hat wie
hier in kenia hat gabi geholfen in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten 760 millionen
kinder in den ärmsten ländern der welt
zu impfen
doch die korona krise gefährdet diese
positive entwicklung
ich habe meine tochter seit ihrer geburt
immer zum impfen gebracht aber seit dem
ausbruch von corona nicht mehr
ich habe angst dass wir uns im
krankenhaus mit dem virus anstecken
allein in afrika haben zuletzt
schätzungsweise 23 millionen kinder ihre
impfungen verpasst weil dies gefährde
weltweit das leben von 6000 kindern
täglich so die eindringliche warnung
deshalb wurde auf der heutigen
geberkonferenz versucht über
sechseinhalb milliarden euro für
impfprogramme zu sammeln krankheiten
kennen keine grenzen
deshalb ist die umfassende finanzierung
von gabi für den weiteren fortschritt so
wichtig selbstverständlich standen auch
die entwicklung und verteilung eines
impfstoffes gegen die kogit 19
erkrankung im mittelpunkt unsere
stiftung gibt zusätzliche 100 millionen
dollar um dazu beizutragen dass ein
zukünftiger impfstoff gegen cupid 19
auch wirklich für jeden zugänglich ist
denn ein solcher impfstoff muss ja
milliardenfach produziert werden die
gefahr ist groß dass die menschen in
reichen ländern dazu erst zum zuge
kommen
schrecksekunde heute in norwegen für die
menschen im kleinen ort alter im norden
des landes ein erdrutsch spülte acht
häuser ins meer
die bewohner konnten rechtzeitig in
sicherheit gebracht werden
die erste von mehreren schlammlawinen
war rund 500 meter breit und 30 meter
hoch der altar fjord an dem die
schlammlawinen abgingen ist ein
beliebtes reiseziel
und damit sind wir in der sendung beim
blick aufs wetter es beruhigt sich nur
kurz ab morgen mittag gibt es kräftige
schauer und gewitter
ausführlich kommt der wetterbericht in
etwa 20 minuten von gunther tiersch
um 22 uhr heute journal und ein gespräch
mit dem bundesfinanzminister olaf scholz
das war es von uns wir danken für ihr
großes interesse ich wünsche ihnen allen
einen angenehmen abend und gebe gleich
weiter an bettina schausten und peter
frey jetzt im zdf sie haben fragen an
die bundeskanzlerin
[Musik]
mit liebe zuschauer mit neuem regen wird
es morgen noch kühler jetzt zieht heute
nacht zunächst erstmal der starke regen
im nordosten ab teilweise noch mit
heftigen gewittern im süden wird es auch
in dieser nacht weiter regnet morgen
vormittag zieht sich der regen dann dort
zu den alten zurück sonst beginnt der
tag erst mal trocken aber im westen geht
es ab mittag los neue schauer und
gewitter die bis zur mitte deutschlands
voran kommen während es im osten doch
trocken bleibt später auch im süden und
wir haben einen starken zum teil
stürmischen südwest die temperaturen
meist so 14 grad im westen aber 18 19
grad noch mal im osten und die
aussichten wechselhaft der sonntag wird
ein bisschen freundlicher zumindest in
der mitte deutschlands
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut